say for example like you know every ax
which is in july
i usually go like i usually go to
america for like
remember yeah i usually go to america
from anywhere between one to three
months right because i'm
going around i'm visiting places what
not and so i have to make a backlog
right
i mean i could technically just make
videos while i'm at aki's parents place
yeah yeah
but that would be [ __ ] weird and i
don't want to use my time on holiday
because it's technically a holiday to
[ __ ] worry about work so
two months before that i just grind i
grind like
[ __ ] crazy and i make like legit two
to three months worth of videos ahead i
don't know how long
that's like something i have that's a
well i have never heard of
dude last year i made 12 videos ahead i
wish i wish i could be that ahead man i
wish
i like wake up and i i dream of that
moment and it was great because
for those one to three months that i was
away because we also went to like europe
and stuff in like yeah i went to go see
you and yeah i went to go see everyone
all my friends in europe and all my
friends in america
the thought of youtube was just
completely gone i just i turned back
into just
regular joey yeah two months yeah and it
was so liberating but
it's a double-edged sword right because
when you're not thinking
about your job or doing youtube for that
long
and you come back to it it's like taking
a gap year at uni it is a little
difficult to get back into yeah but you
also might come into it more refreshed
than ever oh no
yeah that's that's what i mean that's
why it's a double a sword because it can
easily be either
one of the two you can either come back
and be like i have like 20 new ideas
or you could come back and be like [ __ ]
i don't want to do this i think
the point that was the biggest turning
point for me was getting an editor
like oh yes and i know that ever you
always think that like youtubers always
like man
but i've just got this touch to it and
i'm like no you're [ __ ] wrong
you are actually just wrong there is
someone who could do it better than you
because that's their job to
just do that they can do it better and
faster better
faster and guess what you have free time
now yeah you know what that's like
you've never had that before
and i sucked at editing yeah [ __ ] i
mean can't talk
i convinced joey to get an editor yeah
because i i because
up until what less than two years ago i
was editing all of my videos still
and like i remember back in the early
days of youtube people used to be iffy
about like viewers used to get like
pissed if you had an editor yeah but not
anymore i'm glad that it's changed yeah
that's like sponsorships right it's yeah
yeah yeah because you're like accepting
the way i see it is that i've gotten
better editing
and now i have more time to make better
videos and i can make more ambitious
videos because i'm not the one
because the worst thing was is that like
i want to make this video ambitious but
i don't want to add more work in post
for myself
so it was always like yeah yeah you
would always limit yourself because
you're like i don't want to have to add
work
see i'm i'm see that's okay this is
again this is this cycle
this is my problem i'm because i'm
apparently i'm a [ __ ] workaholic
you are a workaholic just i don't know
like i just want to feel ahead of my
work for once in my life and it's really
hard because
i don't know even too hands-on yeah i am
too hands-on but even like even if i
have an editor
i i need to learn how to just see what
the viewer sees right
because every time i get an editor every
time i come up with a finished video i
can always be like i can make this
better
i can i i can i can improve this by an
extra little bit and i always end up
doing it that's the
that's i guess that's the bad thing
about being a perfectionist right is
that like you're never satisfied
like but i mean you could argue that
yeah maybe that extra touch you do
put in is the reason why you've done so
well yeah you know why everyone comes to
watch
your videos on the anime right maybe it
is maybe it also
it wouldn't [ __ ] matter at all yeah i
don't know i don't know if this is just
like
why don't you test though why don't you
do it yes test it out just let allen
just just do
all of the editing yeah because they all
[ __ ] kill me
but this is the thing you've got to do
you've got to let go of it you've got to
let go
here's the thing right because it's not
just about one video
it's it's as we know you can't get
enough metrics or enough analytics of
one video
that's true like you can make the
[ __ ] what you feel is like the worst
[ __ ] video
of your channel and for some reason it
does well yeah what does it mean what if
you put it out there
and it's nothing happens like it's yeah
oh [ __ ]
i can just let him do because that
because the exact opposite happened with
me when you talked me into hiring mood
on yeah to be my editor i was like okay
mudan watches my videos so he should
have a good grasp of it all right i'll
let him edit like the first couple of
videos
yeah dude the first couple of videos i
feel so bad for towards moonlight
because i made him redo that first video
like five times
i was like all right add this little
zoom in here no i would have added this
here i would have added this here
and i feel so bad now mood on but
nowadays i could just be like all right
move on
here's the script here's the raw files
go ham fam and he always
just nails it i think one of the biggest
things that an editor does as well at
least for
our kind of content is that dude i do so
much embarrassing [ __ ] that i would
delete
for sure oh yeah never make it into the
cut that they would put in
yeah and the first time i saw it i'm
like i don't really like that that
i look kind of [ __ ] stupid there yeah
and then
after a while i'm like i guess that's
kind of funny and it adds a bit of charm
so now
now if i ever work with anyone who edits
my videos i'm like please make me look
as stupid as [ __ ]
make me look so [ __ ] dumb yeah yeah
please poke fun at me the whole
full monkey brain yeah yeah mate just
poke fun of me because like i mean
that's
what's funny and now i find that funny
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but very british self-doubt very much so
yeah but i also like now
because i work with multiple editors now
um so like i always just tell them now
to just
throw in as much of your personality
into your editing as best as possible
because
i feel that like the landscape of
youtube editors has kind of changed in
the sense that now
youtube editors have almost become their
own
identity in a video where like you know
like perfect examples like game grumps
for example right yeah like
barry the first editor was just as much
of an important
aspect of game grumps as the hosts were
right and i feel that like with a lot of
youtubers
their editor is kind of just become
another part
of that person's like personality right
so yeah
and i feel it just completely makes for
a different type of video but
also makes it really unique at the same
time and i guess i guess that's why i'm
having such a hard time letting go
because i feel like
what i do what i do is i put my
personality
into like i let alan do like the hard
like most most of the work and
like the other five percent is just me
and like i'm self inserting myself into
my videos but i feel like it's because
of it's because of that that
you know people people know me or like
why sit down in first places because my
videos are very personal and it's like
my personality reflected not only in
like my script but my editing as well
and the way like i
um you've known you and alan have known
each other for so long oh yeah yeah i
feel like alan would have a
good grasp of yours he definitely
definitely does he definitely does there
are
there are some videos that take no
effort at all for him to edit and
there's some videos where he's like i
don't know what the [ __ ]
it's i don't know it's a difficult
balance i'm still working on it it's
it's funny that i'm like 13 years into
my youtube career or whatever
someone figured this [ __ ] out